and with just days left before Republicans
regained control of the house house Democrats
released six years worth of former president
Donald Trump's tax returns the nearly 6 000
pages of documents cap off a years-long battle
between the former president and Congress
Scott McFarland reports from Washington six
years of former president Trump's tax returns
reveal he paid 750 in federal income tax in
2016 and 2017 and nothing in 2020 claiming
more business losses than earnings how is
he in a position to pay so little some years
less than you and me in income taxes it's
a great question look the tax code is is extremely
complicated president Trump has utilized the
tax code to his Advantage Democrats went all
the way to the Supreme Court to get their
hands on the returns after Trump defied Decades
of tradition declining to release them voluntarily
as a candidate then as president Democrats
publicly posted the documents four days before
they lose control of the U.S House the power
of the presidency is so great and so unique
we need to make sure that that person regardless
of party is above reproach the returns also
show zero charitable donations listed in 2020
despite Trump's pledge to donate his four
hundred thousand dollar a year presidential
salary to charity so we can't tell if he was
telling the truth when he said he was donating
a salary or not but again upon IRS audit they
would ask for those kinds of documentation
from the tax preparer but Democrats say the
returns revealed Trump wasn't audited by the
IRS as he'd claimed and as it was expected
of the IRS during much of the presidency Trump
in a recorded statement called the release
a political attack the seizure of these confidential
records was completely unconstitutional there
is no legitimate legislative purpose for their
action and if you look at what they've done
it's so sad for our country Republicans on
the house Ways and Means Committee were also
critical of the release of the tax returns
and they take control of the panel as Republicans
take control of the house Tuesday with the
new Congress for CBS Saturday morning I'm
Scott McFarland in Washington